die ereignisse kombinieren es wird
tatsächlich immer wahrscheinlicher dass
schon in diesem jahrzehnt eine
mondstation gebaut wird nach mehreren
jahrzehnten gibt es wieder eine rakete
die menschen außerhalb des objekts
transportieren könnte ein flug zum mond
oder mars reicht aber nicht aus wenn man
dort nicht auch leben können bauprojekte
auf dem mond sind momentan noch reine
science fiction aber forscher innen
arbeiten bereits daran habitate auf dem
mond zu errichten in denen
astronautinnen tatsächlich für längere
zeiträume leben könnten dabei sollen
algen für genügend sauerstoff werden und
urin zu trinkwasser klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal und
aktive die glocke nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's dazu kommen eine
trostlose wüstenlandschaft mit
temperaturen von über 100 grad celsius
am tag und bis zu minus 170 grad in der
nacht überall feiner grauer staub
weltraum strahlung und sonnensturm
gefahr besonders gemütlich ist der mond
als lebensraum von astronautinnen nicht
umso wichtiger ist es dass ihr wohnraum
gut geplant und mit allem wichtigen
ausgestattet wird für die arbeiten auf
dem mond leben astronautinnen monatelang
auf engstem raum zusammen um ihnen das
möglichst angenehm zu machen werden
besondere habitate vom dem zentrum für
angewandte raumfahrttechnologie und
mikrogravitation der universität bremen
geplant
die geophysikerin christian nach einiger
zwei jahre lang eine solche station
entwickelt die auf dem mond und dem mars
zum einsatz kommen soll
sie besteht aus sechs modulen die
eingeteilt sind im schlafbereich küche
freizeitraum labor werkstatt und es gibt
sogar ein gewächshaus diese segmente
sind alle miteinander verbunden sind
zylinder förmlich gebaut und mit jeweils
sieben metern ganz schön hoch sie würden
auf dem mond oder mars in einer art
hangar mit einer bis zu einem meter
dicken betonwand stehen die sie vor der
aggressiven strahlung und sonnenstürmen
schützt für haneke steht sicherheit an
oberster stelle
aber auch die funktionalität muss
stimmen wenn eine klimaanlage die
stromversorgung mit steckdosen und
beleuchtung und optimale arbeitsflächen
auf der station ist das labor das
wissenschaftliche herz studie sollen in
zukunft proben von mondgestein
untersucht werden die aufschluss über
die entstehung unseres trabanten geben
sollen das labor modul hat eine
grundfläche von 15 quadratmetern und
in zwei stockwerke aufgeteilt es steht
in originalgröße in einer halle des
zahmen natürlich soll auch eine
möglichst hohe lebensqualität
gewährleistet werden in freizeit modul
gibt es deshalb keine zwischendecke
damit die bewohner innen wenigstens dort
ein weiträumiges gefühl haben auch über
den einbau von fenstern wird nachgedacht
was eine ganz schöne herausforderung für
die ingenieurinnen ist eine kuh von
astronauten verbringt bis zu eineinhalb
jahre mal das ist für die menschen eine
echte psychische herausforderung
schließlich können astronautinnen
während einer mission nicht mal eben
über das wochenende wegfahren oder
urlaub nehmen
es gibt keinen abstand zu den
kolleginnen und keine mentalen auszahlen
deshalb plädiert auch volker schmid
raumfahrt ingenieur und leiter der
abteilung iss-astronauten raumfahrt und
exploration am deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt dafür dass die
habitate so gestaltet werden dass die
psyche der astronautinnen keinen schaden
nimmt deshalb dürfen sie nicht einfach
nur praktische blechkisten seien
außerdem kann man auf dem mond nicht mal
eben zum nächsten supermarkt laufen oder
einen wasseranschluss legen aber wie
funktioniert dann das überleben im all
die habitate müssen autarke
lebenserhaltungssysteme sein ressourcen
sind bei weltraummissionen begrenzt das
bremer habitat projekt mama muh nennt
myspace analog das beschäftigt sich
deshalb intensiv mit der
wiederaufbereitung dabei werden zu anno
bakterien auch als blaualgen genannt
eingesetzt um sauerstoff zu produzieren
auch wasser muss mal wieder verwertet
werden auf der raumstation iss wird zum
beispiel der urin der astronautinnen
durch ein filtersystem aufbereitet dass
ihn als sauberes wasser zurück ins
versorgungssystem leitet so kann eine
tasse kaffee die heute getrunken wird
morgen wieder getrunken werden solche
systeme haben auch für das leben auf der
erde eine große bedeutung die autarken
stationen können wichtige erkenntnisse
bieten weil die herausforderung im
grunde dieselben sind im all aber unter
verschärften bedingungen bestehen müssen
im besten fall regen sie zu neuen
lösungen auf unserer erde an
derzeit gibt es auf der welt ein gutes
dutzend von testdaten die bisher vor
allem für die erde gebaut wurden um
vereinzelte technische systeme zu testen
organisatorische abläufe zu üben und den
psychischen zustand der test bewohner
innen zu beobachten allerdings könnte
kein einziges dieser test systeme bisher
den realen bedingungen auf dem mond
stand halten bevor also irgendwas
so eine station mit einer rakete in
richtung mars oder mond geschickt wird
gibt es noch einiges zu tun auch das
habitat in bremen besteht aktuell noch
größtenteils aus holz und gipskarton das
ziel des mamba projektes ist es eines
tages eine 1 1 kopie des modells auf dem
mond aufstellen zu können um den
menschen dort das überleben zu sichern
wann genau das sein wird steht sozusagen
noch in den sternen
laut raumfahrt ingenieur schmid hat die
nasa das jahr 2028 für die nächste
mondlandung genannt was die us-regierung
jahr um vier jahre vorgezogen hatte also
2024 auch die stationen luna gateway ist
in planung sie zieht ihre bahnen um den
mond und könnte helfen nachhaltiger zur
mondoberfläche runter und wieder rauf zu
kommen ein aufbau von habitaten auf dem
mond könnte dann nach dem 2000 30er
jahren passieren mond raumstation
konkrete pläne
hier gibt es mehr infos zum dieb gateway
der geplanten raumstation die für den
montag geplant ist also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren oder noch
cooler kanal mitglied werden hier
bekommen die videos schneller zu sehen
und wir bekommen einen kleinen beitrag
um weiter dieses einzigartige projekt
mit täglichen videos aus dem
themenbereich wissenschaft weiter zu
machen also bis dann bleibt dran